what would you recommend to a family
member or
an individual who has been
diagnosed with mnd or
als as we call it or lou carrick's
um
as far as
support
or i guess yeah that's a very broad
question so many things
i'm sure they can read up on what to
expect physically
but i think maybe emotionally
what would you recommend to someone i
think emotionally if
try and keep your humor there or try and
keep yourselves as much as possible the
disease keeps taking things from you
physically taking things from you
and if you can keep your own
personalities as you know as true to
yourself without letting the disease
take that as well
then
um
it can make life
bearable it can make life easier
um
and also
do ask for help within
you know before you're absolutely
exhausted and on your knees
it's hard to ask for help i don't know
what that is about our human nature but
sometimes we find it
easier to struggle on and cope than to
just ask the nearest person for help
but also for
for family members around
for extended family members or friends
i think i would hope that our film
will help them know how to help without
waiting to be asked
um
i mean i was
i learned
to look to people's strengths
and then tailor the help that i needed
um so ask directly for you know
somebody's good at cooking
could you cook us some dinners
and bring them along or you know i even
have i had an auntie who was really
she knew her classical music a lot
better than i did and and neil was
really struggling to get to sleep some
nights and
um we only had a little bit of music
that he found soothing and he was
starting to get used to that so i asked
her
you know i don't have time to
troll through music looking for
something that neil might find soothing
would you do that for me would you send
it to me and that you know
that little thing
can
can really improve quality of life
um
and you know and anything that takes
time
for a carer
you know bills accounts
cooking
cleaning
anything like that that will give you
another five minutes with your family
your child your you know your partner
who's suffering or he's
you know
needing to speak to you
um that's invaluable
so just
you know if
if you're feeling i don't know how to
help
then look at what you're good at and
help in the way that you're you know you
think you'd be good at helping
i remember one time someone else telling
me about someone that was faced with a
life-threatening disease and i said oh
that sounds terrible and the person
stopped me and they said well what that
person needs is your empathy not your
sympathy
so how can we what can we do to
recommend that
it's a fine line because you don't want
to
feel sorry for someone but at the same
time you want to show that support just
remember they're the same person
even though they've been
given some terrible news they're the
same person
and they're still going to laugh at the
same things that you were laughing at
last week with them
you know
they're still going to enjoy the same
things they haven't
physically changed as people they
haven't you know
um i think
certainly
sympathy is a difficult one because i
did find it
incredibly hard if if i was you know um
getting through a day
day by day
and then somebody else came to my door
and started crying and i found that
quite hard
um i found it
you know
quite hard that they couldn't
wait to cry until they've gone home
but you know everybody's different and
and and i i
i did cry in the beginning and but i i
quickly had to
learn to
manage
our situation and and be the strong one
so you know
it is hard for somebody that's looking
from the outside and thinking
just instantly that must be terrible
that must be awful but actually when you
look at
death it's not
i
perhaps because i had oscar and i
experienced the birth thing so close to
to neil's diagnosis
i find it very hard that we really
celebrate one
and we don't celebrate the other when
essentially they're the same thing going
in opposite directions
and when we find one really really hard
to deal with and then the other one
completely
excited and celebrated
um
when you know
birth's not always the happiest for
everybody either but i think universally
we think that
that one's awful and one's
great
i don't i don't know if i'm explaining
that properly but and i just find them i
think because i experienced the two so
close together
i do find that somewhere in the middle
you know society sort of separates them
so much and we can look at one very
easily and we can't look at the other
one at all
and
i don't think we should separate
life from life i think right
so it sounds like then just remember to
treat the person
as you did before they're still the same
individual they don't need
you know the oh
just just to treat them just as you
would the same jokes the same everything
yeah they're the same person
yep
anything to add
and
yeah i think it's hard
because i think we're often afraid of
somebody else's suffering
and
maybe neil made it easier for us to look
at by sharing this blog and what he
shared in the film
but
what we found is through
we
he used social media to
write his blog and to connect to
community and this community in a way
is now growing with the film and i think
what we're discovering is
that that same vulnerability that he
shared people are now sharing with each
other
and
also through our facebook page and
certain screenings that we've been doing
internationally
and i think you know the film now
screened in something like 45 countries
and
all of that i think
here was somebody who was vulnerable
about his suffering
and
i think that that is the connection that
keeps the film going there
and i think we live in a society that
doesn't want to show that vulnerability
you know
uh
we can't believe that we're mortal
and neo
made us look at that
that's for me it's just
he's still being the same person he's
still he was very much a sociable person
i always explained him as a gatherer
he'd be the one to organize the party
and get people together and everyone was
welcome and he's still doing that you
know he's you know for me i feel like
he's
you know
this is screened in 45 countries
and and when you're
in
the house and it's just you know you and
your partner and your family and this
awful thing happening you can't believe
that there's no
connection to other people it's
it's a really hard thing to deal with
you feel like you're nobody knows about
this disease nobody knows what's going
on in your house and
and actually when people start talking
you do find that there is
a lot of um empathy and community and
and you're not going through it alone
and i think that's what's fantastic
about the film really as well is that
it's he's still bringing people together
she's lovely
and
not not just people
from the ls
no community i hate calling the
community but
um but the fact that that people are you
know taking a lot about life from the
film is fantastic
you